bon alors tu a repéré un sport et j'ai
trouvé un bon spot les gars très facile
d'accès en plus
ouais c'est la mère n'ont pas je vais
trop johan tapas ouais ça va être
pratique pour évacuer la ferraille latin
oui beaucoup
sa femme a toujours été un peu mouillée
à la fin bon bah super beaux spots donc
c'est parti pour le premier lancer de la
journée sous ce beau pont
ou alors on trouve à pour un premier
lancé c'est quand même très moyen mais
bon juste raté un truc n'est pas venu un
truc pas rien c'est fou ça quand j'ai
quelque chose là je crois à france est
nulle
jacqueline concerne
tout ça ouais t'es vase faut passer
plusieurs fois bon bien gratter au nom
encore une qui concerne de merde non
mais regardez moi toutes ces bonnes
choses qu'un jeu poulet basquaise au
piment d'espelette
non mais à ce prix là tu son rôle du
terrain dans la boue a encore qui arrive
bon les gars après vingt minutes de
combat avec ce truc le barbarian group a
fait ses preuves
regardez moi c'est plus alors qu'à ce
que ses coffres forts non je pense pas
la forme n'est pas
allez pas en faveur d'un corps
[Musique]
au bout du bout ce joli oui oui il est
beau sympa mais surtout il est super
bien pour faire baisser leur garde de
réservoirs à leurs affaires ouais ça
pour le coup tu perdes sa sauvegarde
cela nous donne c'est un passionné il
peut nous remonter quelque chose ça doit
être restauré sa perte nette à leur aide
à voir qui est pas perçue donc non il
est très sympa pour les très très dur à
désenvaser incroyable je pense ici
ouais ici c'est vraiment plein de potes
je pense qu'il est très très sympa a le
truc de talent comme quoi le bar va il
fait la différence
merci m et dans la détection attends je
te le pic pourtant un cadre vas-y
puissant à la douille
je sais pas peut-être autre chose avec
le faut le sortir vasisht et le bois ah
oui donc c'est que ça c'est peut-être
que ça ça donne ça mais vu la forme
qu'il a il ya peut-être leur accroché
par contre aux wem sont là bas non pour
ces playoffs
j'ai pas voulu si c'est beaucoup c'est à
vous de vos formes de poisson mais
peut-être rien mais c'est peut-être ça
qui nous embête et depuis tout à l'heure
le poids ou une grosse barre de fer
pourtant les la base seco qui a accroché
un panneau un panneau en bois c'est
super c'est super dur les panneaux en
bois
hélas trop beau existe plus non
seulement faudrait par contre il est
interdit de stationner mais super vieux
voilà je suis aussi super ça c'est quoi
l'idée d'un hyper violent en bois tu as
vu comme il a pris cher le détacher du
bois en face parfois transportés
ouais bon du coup vous entendez sur
moins de bruit je vais vous montrer
pourquoi
allaient ils sont en train de nettoyer
le canal comme nous mais avec des plus
gros moyens tara ça bouge la sage les
gelé fin j'ai un truc à ça a lâché
ouais il avancer et avancer où il a
bougé a bien raison je vais chez
décoincer non mais ça va pas ça tu
remontes c'est pas léger
coûte non quand même pas
à un petit vélo des familles non
à unique elle
[Musique]
allez michel hahn hon chaque cliente
mincir plus la six c'est quoi ces
chargeurs ne rend service
on dirait un jour peut-être scolari
c'est vrai quoi que il est vide c'est un
vrai t'es sur qui les cinq ans c'est
remonter vers le haut en fanfare le
ressorte fra s'est pas dites sens
inverse
je sais pas me presser en métal bref
c'est dur à dire je crois pour et après
c'est la vie je veux dire les ressorts
et sont pas là non c'est pas comme ça
wayne on le ressent mais pas comme ça
contre caby way salon je sais pas trop
ouais différents toutes avaient tiré
loin
[Musique]
magistrate est temps d'aller à l'hôpital
un chargeur en même temps l époque comme
ça tu es obligé mais elle est à nos fans
enfin à sa ferais comme un grand à paris
aw deux filles stoll le tampon membrane
essentiel de l'audition est
particulièrement sensible de fâcher il
est poussé goeldi paie des charges des
scooters des panneaux et à kohat dans la
caboche au un morceau de tendeurs au
massacre
qu'est ce que c'est que c'est peut-être
le guen en attend au nom de la merde on
dirait ok il ya un caillou non non c'est
quoi un règlement c'est ça qui attire
choix s'est plaint que des travaux
dommage on ya cru à chaque fois c'est la
montée de way toute impression va
surtout s'attacher à charger juste avant
c'est ça je pense que si ces plaquettes
par contre si vous avez des idées je
n'ai jamais vu ça
est ce que ces gens n'ont pas du tout
le lait je les attends moi je les jeux
les ouais tu vois force de persévérer
un vélo
nickel pas il est dieu et compact
c'était un assez lourd les sympa non une
barrière une barrière je pense au point
des deux je suis là et va pas entrer
dans l'hôtel
ouais bon allez on continue un bel chef
presque remise à l'eau bon alors tourner
a pas que mouillé alors on va devoir
sauter assez bon papa ballé bougera pas
elle est partie
[Musique]
ou c'est lourd
on me voit la scène j'en ai caché
terminé qu énormément de choses sont
cependant qu'il avait sûrement jamais
été fait malgré tout à lescar et on a pu
sortir un plein de vélos
ouais c'était plutôt pas mal voilà je
suis plutôt content de ce cadre-là qui a
une très belle couleur lorsqu'on allume
à faire avec ça on se connait pas trop
mais voilà d'ailleurs en commentaires si
vous voulez ou si vous savez ce qu'on
peut en faire n'hésitez pas à nous dire
après ce très beau charge donc de
pistolet c'est sûrement un vrai de
mohéli vide et on n'a pas trouvé d'armes
donc il va falloir revenir pour la
trouve une réalité on reviendra
reviendra et peut-être même la semaine
prochaine ciao